let's go back first to this idea of
decentralization right in non crypto you
know technology the idea of a founder
being able to you know really drive go
through obstacles recruit people and set
this vision that we've kind of made it
you know really sexy to be a founder
right as a former founder it's really
crappy you're like you haven't showered
in a week you haven't eaten a proper
meal you've no idea what's going on
you're emotionally exhausted you're
constantly living between a state of
euphoria and like tremendous
soul-crushing anxiety but yes it's the
duck analogy right so if you look at a
duck in water above the water they're
cool calm and collected below water
they're just paddling as fast as they
possibly can as they don't drown right
but but you know in this decentralized
world this idea that there is no leader
right and and you don't need to have a
single point of failure or that you know
threat component how do you think
founders and leadership play into a
decentralized world and is it important
that's a really interesting question I
don't think I have a definitive answer
but I gotten going back to this idea of
hearts and minds and how humans operate
I think that people are drawn to
characters even though the crypto
community to some degree tries to be
decentralized what's really interesting
is we have a very strong cast of
characters they're very opinionated and
very loud what I think it goes back to
ultimately is look I've been in the
venture space for quite some time and
what's what's interesting about it is in
the venture space the way that founders
operate you're running a company right
companies require organization and the
reason that the corporate form was
created it's really just a governance
structure right because establishing
contracts for every single piece of work
every single transaction doesn't make
sense so the corporate form was created
to line incentives between investors
employees managers stakeholders in that
entity
and they're all incentivized to work
together to reduce common set of goals
and that's reinforced by legal contracts
financial incentives and the terms of
shareholder value and bonus structures
and how people get compensated and it's
taken us 200 years to get to a workable
corporate form right and we see that
reflected in the size of the equities
market people are willing to put
trillions of dollars into that corporate
form in the form of investing in stock
what's interesting about crypto is there
is no such form right the crypto firm
are what I like to call the theory of
the crypto firm is highly immature
because this is this is new but what we
see is people are trying to replicate
things that have existed in the
corporate form for the last two
centuries in the crypto firm and it
doesn't quite work because right now if
you're an investor and you're putting
capital into a crypto firm or someone
who's capitalizing their company through
a token you have no rights you know
preppin or preferences there are no
covenants there's no legal contract that
binds that founder to do anything on
your behalf and what you then see is
their tremendous abuses of power there's
tremendous degree of moral hazard and I
think I don't mean that to say that
people set out with that intent I just
think the form were using is perhaps not
appropriate for what we're trying to do
so I think the narrative around security
tokens is really compelling because
investors can understand that but when
you say to someone if you read the terms
of some of these tokens know there's a
disclaimer in every token sale that says
you've no rights you're not entitled to
anything
we're not promising that we'll give you
anything so the idea that we're going to
give people billions of dollars on the
basis of social trust I think is an
imperfect idea because block chains
don't change human nature